okay good evening i want to thank
everyone for being here this evening
and i want to thank our media partners
for being with us throughout the day
to help us get critical news and
information out at this time i'm going
to introduce
mayor john cooper who has a brief update
for everyone
he's also here with chief drake and
swann
from police and fire who can also take
your questions
so this time i'm going to call on
nashville's mayor john cooper
well thank you all for being here i'm
the chief the chiefs and i just have had
a walking tour of the devastation
on 2nd avenue and
as of you know as of right now it does
initial evidence does show that the
early morning explosion was a
was a deliberate bomb being set off in
our community
and the blast caused injuries and
catastrophic
damage to this very historic part of
nashville
now at the end of the day i think all of
us i certainly have gone from relief
that there were not more casualties and
that's a an amazing thing that there
were not
particularly when people began to see
the the devastation on 2nd avenue to
relief that there were not more
casualties to now
anger and determination and resolve
and a resolve to be to rebuild and not
to be deterred
and to bring whoever was responsible for
this to justice
now i've spoken with governor lee who is
working
with us to have a declaration of a civil
emergency
both with the state and then for tema to
work with fema
to bring all possible resources
to commit to rebuilding second avenue to
go forward not being deterred by this
and i'm grateful to our state and our
federal partners
to help this important part of nashville
rebuild and come back
there are 41 at least separate
businesses that are
materially damaged by this blast there
will be
others
as we see the full extent of this but
already
you can tell that it's going to need
special help special resources and i'm
grateful to the state
partnering with us to commit
to rebuilding second now and i want to
stand with our
downtown residents and our business
owners
for whom this was a terrible day but we
are
like nashville has faced other
challenges particularly this year
we can rebuild and and get back to
normal now as announced earlier metro is
also establishing a curfew
in the explosion impact area from 4 30
today
until 4 30 p.m this sunday now affected
businesses
i would urge them to contact crystal app
at the central precinct
862 8600 to be able to manage coming
back to your
facilities safely but in the meantime
the curfew area is going to provide
safety and security for businesses
in this area and i will go ahead and
warn nashville
it will be some time before second
avenue is back to normal it is not going
to be the three days of the curfew for
second avenue itself the curfew
is going to go from 4th to the river
from james robertson
down to broadway the police are going to
take special care with that for the next
few days
and our partners at the fbi do have a
large crime scene to investigate and
they need to be able to do that work
effectively and well
now this morning's attack on our
community was intended to create chaos
and fear
in this season of peace and hope
but nashvillians have proven time and
time again that the spirit of our city
cannot be broken
but we're not going to rest until those
responsible for this outrageous and
cowardly attack
are brought to justice and the full
force of the metro police and our
partners with the fbi and the atf
are working together to make sure that
we will get back
to being the safe city that we
are now three people have been
hospitalized as a result
of the explosion are in stable condition
and my prayers are with them
and their loved ones tonight i had to
was able to visit with a four-year-old
girl this morning who
was had no injury and was
saved but let's just spend a moment in
celebration of the six
uniformed metro police officers from our
central precinct
who are at the scene at the time of the
blast these incredible heroes
who ran to danger with uncertain
outcomes ahead of them
were responsible for so many
injuries being saved now i've spoken
with chief drake
the officers who were injured by this
are recovering well i would like chief
drake to come and
spend a little bit of valuing officers
hosey
llewellyn wells seapost hopping and
sergeant miller
who took swift action and directed
people away
from danger to save lives even at the
time that their own lives would have
been in peril they are heroes
and i am grateful to them and all of
nashville's first responders this is a
year
where we understand what first
responders mean to our community
time and time again and unfortunately on
christmas day you have another example
of that
now several downtown residents whose
homes were destroyed by the blast and i
am inspired by their resilience
and we have to draw inspiration from
them as our city to be resilient
once again and to get the resources to
rebuild
and i'm grateful to the red cross who's
opened an aid shelter at the east park
community center for those who have been
displaced
now with that let me turn this over to
the chief and answer
questions i think the message of today
is we are going from
relief now to resolve
to catch those folks and to rebuild our
city and one more challenge in
nashville's 2020 but we will get through
it
and we're grateful to our first
responders and never
you know you see all once again
these officers running into danger to
help save
lives and injury it's inspiring
and again the gratitude of our community
goes to the
chiefs force and with that i'd like to
turn it over to chief drake to come in a
little bit more specifically about the
heroism
the great heroism of our department
thank you
thank you mayor cooper as mayor cooper
stated these officers acts of heroism is
just tremendous
this morning they received calls for
shots fired i had no idea what they were
responding to once they arrived
in the area they heard an rv giving out
a message
uh basically saying that it was going to
detonate within a certain time frame
and a countdown would go on and uh
and then it was play music and then the
countdown would start again
officers immediately began knocking on
doors
and evacuating residents here not
knowing if
the bomb was going to detonate
immediately or if it was going to go off
in the time that it was stated
these officers didn't care about
themselves they didn't think about that
they cared about the citizens of
nashville and they went in and we'd be
talking
not about the debris and that we have
here but also maybe
potential people so with that said the
officers
save lives today and their heroism
should be noted
sir do you believe that either the
lyft headquarters or the at t data
center might have been targets of this
explosion
we don't know the investigation is
continuing we don't know the motive at
this time
but we're following up on all available
leads is there any timing chief at all
why this happened christmas morning
anything
to lead you to believe that this day was
chosen in particular
we don't have anything at this time
we're following up on every lead that we
can
why christmas morning we have no idea it
was a total surprise in fact when i was
brief this morning i
i thought maybe it was going to be a
propane explanation explosion
from an rv and it turned out to be an
intentional act but we
we're going to follow up on every lead
we're following up on tips that come in
now
and so we'll continue our investigative
efforts have you found human remains
in the debris we have found tissue that
we believe could be
remains and we'll just have that
you know examine and then we'll be able
to let you know from that point
i'm sorry i can't
well the rv was detonated so if it was
someone inside we have no idea
such a large explosion but the
investigations continue in this
matter all over the area down there and
so we'll continue to examine that
to see if it is human remains right
right now there's no known fatalities
that we know of
so just the tissues is what you believe
that you found human tissue
in the remains is what you believe we we
believe
could be but we be for certain we have
to examine it
and once we know for sure that's uh and
then we'll let everyone know but we're
investigating it
have you received any uh information of
threats leading up to the city in the
coming days
anything to lead you to believe that
this was something that was coming
we we have not received any threats
whatsoever i was total
total surprise as as i said when we got
the call that when i got the call this
morning
uh i thought it was going to be a camper
someone was trying to keep warm
it's a gas leak and it was an explosion
as i got more updates that's when i
found out it was intentional
that we had no pre-warnings at all what
do you make of the timing
of this being that there are no people
out on the street at six in the morning
and that it happened with the
announcement playing in advance
yeah i don't want to speculate but you
would think that
uh this person didn't want to harm
people that maybe just wanted to
uh destroy but we're not sure until we
you know get further into the
investigation
can you talk about the 911 impact by
this obviously several cities
have had their 911 systems knocked out
because of this
do you think that was the relation here
was the intention to knock out 9-1-1
services
we're not sure right now we're following
up on that we're aware we did have some
services go down we did have a t go down
for just a little while
but that's back up now so if to say
anything more
be speculation i'm actually going to ask
for that to be last question for chief
for just now we're going to ask chief
swan from metrofire to come and give an
update
okay thank you
good evening i know there's a lot of
questions unanswered questions that we
have
questions that we can't answer right now
but some of the things we do want to
talk about we talk about our public
safety and
fire and police and office emergency
management
the things that we do operate off of the
lip method
where we life safety incident
stabilization and property conservation
and so currently right now we've uh we
know we've done a sweep of the all the
buildings to try to make sure that we
cleared
that there is no personnel that are in
the buildings
and we've done all the hazards hazmat
sweeps and all the things that you would
imagine if it's a dirty bomb or
something of this nature
now we have our urban search and rescue
teams in
that way that we can shore up the
buildings we've got our instructional
engineers there to make sure that again
that the buildings are
sound enough to actually be able to
enter in and out of them
so again it's a lot of moving parts and
i know there's a lot of questions that
again that we're trying to answer but at
this point it's just so many moving
parts
so again we just want to take our hats
off to all the first responders
and all the jobs that has been done in
the city
especially right now with the
infrastructure
in the situation it is all the partners
that we have in
local federal working together to make
sure that as the mayor said
we're a resilient city and we'll keep
moving thank you any idea how many
people were evacuated
uh we're actually that's a great
question and we're working on that
because the way
units are designed and we're trying to
get an accurate head count what i can
tell everyone
the red car red cross is partnering with
us
and we have mta or we go buses set up
throughout the city so if there's
anybody that's displaced
we'll take them to the east park
community center and from there
we'll make sure that they have a place
to stay for tonight or
for as long as needed
i will say many people that maybe place
i'm sorry i won't put a number to it but
we know that there are people that are
displaced can you speak to the
structural integrity of the buildings
downtown as given the explosion
is that part of the reason why there's a
curfew for the next few days to make
in case anything collapses absolutely so
at the office of emergency management
when we try to look at the overall view
of the city and making sure that
everything is safe and working together
the we know we had one building collapse
due to the explosion and due to the age
of the other buildings and then we had
water
was being actually displayed throughout
the buildings and with the cold weather
we thank the water department as well
making sure that they've got the water
shut off but still the integrity of
those buildings are in question so we're
trying to make sure
that we do have everybody in place and
um
safety for our personnel what building
that was what building
was that collapsed i don't have that
address i'm sorry
business was inside residential or
anything yeah it was a it was a building
that actually
housed across from the explosion which
above the it was residential above
so i can't really give you that i'm
sorry all right guys
thank you our last question for this
evening i want to thank you guys for
coming out we will be in touch with you
with regular updates
again thank you to mayor cooper to chief
swan and chief drake for being here and
especially to those
officers that we are so grateful for
this evening
you'll hear from us again all right
thank you
okay
i